it's my fifth day in idomeni a place
that gets more unpleasant with each
passing day near non-stop rain has left
the ground muddy and water locked and
this has increased the misery for
Refugees this young man from Syria shows
us what he's doing to keep the water out
of his tent but keeping himself dry is
another matter no my best we don't carry
many clothes with us so we can't just
put something new on since there's no
sunshine I can't dry my clothes they're
all wet it's a hard place to get used to
and so is the smell of a domain even
smoke garbage and faeces 15,000 are
stranded and more keep coming the
refugee camp at egomania is set up like
a small town near the train station
arabic science guide refugees to shops
where they can transfer money a
restaurant across the road that was shot
is open now and catering to its new
customers
despite their desperate situation the
refugees hospitality is overwhelming a
man invites me to drink coffee with him
I meet 22 year old Judy hammer occurred
from Syria who fled the bombs of
dictator bashar al-assad
he tells us of what little food they get
in the camp and that he comes here every
day to eat in to charge his phone for 15
days in Edo Meany he has almost run out
of money then he invites us to his new
home unlike the vast majority of
refugees here shooty found an abandoned
house to live in
together with 25 other man from Syria
shower his friends are just preparing
the shower he says and I'm not quite
sure if I understand it was water for
the shower yeah
hygiene is awful that I don't know what
to say have anything for that just this
each rule sleeps up to five people at
least it's dry he says and that
something he can be happy about in a
place like he don't mean it what we
should be staying here that is better
than from another place yes just behind
the houses the train station
many have set up their tents next to the
tracks so they can avoid sleeping on the
muddy ground further down I find an old
freight car home to for Syrian families
they invite me in to see how they live
just like most here their destination is
Germany a girl asks me what I think
about their situation and then comes the
question on everybody's mind and again I
really don't know what I should tell her
hope and faith are what sustain many
refugees here the promise of safety
offered by German Chancellor Angela
Merkel is something they believe in
I hope they won't be disappointed